more than 12 000 nascar fans nate will
descend on the las vegas motor speedway
starting today is nascar weekend one of
the biggest in-person events we have
seen here in
the city john in nearly a whole year
kate houston live this morning from the
las vegas motor speedway this morning
with a look at how stock car
fans can still have fun even with the
pandemic going on kate good morning to
you
good morning yes that's right normally
this weekend will kick off with some
concerts parades and
big events like that and although that
can't happen nascar and the speedway are
working really hard to make sure that
fans can have fun in person as well as
virtually i'm joined here with mike ford
from nascar thank you so much for being
with us this morning thank you kate it's
great to be here it's great to be back
in las vegas
yeah it's great to have you and you know
normally this would be the uh
second series out on the west coast but
it's the first this year so tell me a
little bit about
what las vegas means to these drivers
and to have fans in person again
uh well when we come out to vegas it's
always a huge deal for nascar
a couple of reasons one vegas loves
nascar and nascar loves vegas we
you know nascar is typically known to be
a southeastern sport
a lot of the drivers are from the
southeast but that's actually a misnomer
we have a number of drivers who are from
las vegas the bush brothers two of the
best drivers in all of nascar
noah gregson in our xfinity series he's
an up and comer you're going to see a
same in the cup series
racing on sundays no in in short amount
of time so they love coming out here
last time we're out here these
grandstands look like this they were
empty
uh now there's gonna be fans and drivers
really bring it up a notch when there's
fans
they'll be doing the burnouts they'll be
driver intros driving around waving at
the fans
there's definitely a different energy so
it's great to have fans back this
weekend
that's so exciting and you know there's
a lot of fans that couldn't make it in
person this time around but there's
still some virtual events
that they can enjoy from the comfort of
their own home would you mind explaining
that virtual garage that's going on that
they can take part in yeah las vegas
motor speedway has done a great job so
the the entire team with marcus smith
leaning at the top at smi
has done a really good job engaging with
the fans if you go to lvms.com
we've got a virtual garage you can tap
find out driver stats
cool interactive videos things like that
so it really makes you feel like you're
at the track when you're watching at 12
30 on sunday
watch the race look at the driver stats
like you would be in reading a program
at the track
listen to nascar.com on the nascar app
we got driver
driver radio communication things like
that a lot of interactive things so when
we had the pandemic last year
we came back without fans we really
tried to ramp up our engagement because
they couldn't come
and we wanted to bring our great sport
to those fans and we're going to
continue that in 2021 even though there
are
fans in the sand this year thank you so
much mike for joining us this morning we
really appreciate it
thank you kate thanks for coming out and
i hope everyone watches on sunday 12 30.
absolutely i'm sure they will and that
first race kicks off tonight at six
of course the grand marshal we're going
to have buffalo bills running back
antonio williams
live on our show at 6 a.m so make sure
to join us then reporting live from the
las vegas motor speedway this morning
kate houston 8 news now